now that's a contract at this point we
define the names of the columns we want
but we still don't have a database to
actually make a database we're going to
extend androids SQLite open helper
SQLite open helper contains cool stuff
to create the database and help us
handle database versioning as we make
changes to our database in the future it
will help us modify our tables for many
apps being able to upgrade to a new
version without data loss is critical
for sunshine we just want to make sure
that upgrades in that involved database
schema changes happen smoothly let's
take a look at SQLite open help or more
closely in action we're going to be
working in the weather DB helper class
that you've been given which extends
SQLite open helper it contains code to
create and initialize the weather
database let's examine it at the
beginning of the DB helper you can see
that we've defined constants for
database version and database name the
database version typically starts at
version 1 and must be manually
incremented each time we release an
updated apk with a new database schema
the database name is the name of the
actual database file in the file system
which will be whether dot DB in our case
note that we're using version 2 since
this revision of the course uses an
updated database version these values
get passed into the constructor to
initialize the database helper next we
have the on create method this is where
the SQL we've been talking about and our
new contract class are used together the
first time the database is used SQLite
open helpers on create will be called we
need to write the correct SQL statement
string so that we can create the table
sunshine needs we then have the system
execute this SQL by calling DB exec SQL
note how we're using all of the weather
entry constants to write our sequel
statements also note that we use lots of
not null constraint on this table these
constraints help prevent us from
inserting records without columns being
filled out to the database and that
helps prevent bugs here is the
implementation of the foreign key
constraint from the not yet created
location entry table this means that we
cannot insert a weather entry into the
database until location entry for the
weather location has been inserted and
we can't delete locations of all there
exists weather entries that point to
them that being said it's going to be a
while before we have UI that can
demonstrate that our database code is
working fortunately there's a way we can
have Android run any code we want even
if there's no UI yet ready Android has a
built-in testing framework that allows
us to create a test apk that executes to
J unit tests that call into classes in
our main apk if you aren't already
familiar with J unit it is a testing
framework that allows you to write
automated test Suites you can run your
automated tests easily you can find your
tests in this section of the Android
studio project just right-click on the
test package and select run once the
tests pass or fail you'll see the output
down here at the bottom of the screen
I'm not going to display the emulator on
our screen because it won't actually
show that we're doing anything the tests
are running don't have any user
interface but you can see here in the
test Runner we're instantiating tests an
empty window and a green result means
the tests succeeded let's look at the
test practice class you can see it sits
in the data package of our test project
and extends Android test case when you
extend Android test case you can
implement the setup method which will be
run before each test you can also
implement teardown which will be run
after each test similar to J unit tests
you simply add new methods in the class
with the prefix test such as test the
demonstrates assertions and those will
automatically be run by the test
processor some other things to note the
full test suite class contains code to
include all of the Java test classes in
its package into a suite of tests the J
unit will run this allows us to easily
add additional tests by just adding
additional Java class files to our test
directory you'll likely have a class
like this in each test project you make
they aren't typically project specific
so you can literally just copy this one
each test should have at least one check
which uses an assert to see if the
program supplies the correct output an
assert is just that it's a declaration
that the outcome after part of a test is
run matches our expectation if the
assert does not
match the test will fail let's look at
our test that demonstrates assertions
and test practice at Java assert equals
asserts that the expected value equals
the actual value if they are not equal
then an assertion fail there is thrown
with a given string message other useful
methods include is cert equals assert
false a certain null or we can just call
fail if a certain code path should never
been reached feel free to write your own
test cases to play with assertions let's
see what happens we make a test fail as
you can see our results are now red and
we can see exactly where in the test our
application failed let's uncomment out
the test create TV function inside of
the test DB class you might have to
import a few classes to get this to
compile
let's also uncomment out the create
North Pole location values and the
insert North Pole location values
functions from within test utilities
this is the last chance to fix up your
location contract if things don't
compile so let's run our new test with
our test DB as you can see we get a
pretty good error message back that our
database was created without both the
location entry and weather entry tables
don't worry we can fix it